Let's start by defining
a database contract
between our data and our model.
A contract is an agreement
between our data model and our view
describing how information is stored.
It will contain all the fields
that our user interface will display.
Let's go into Android Studio
to begin coding.
We'll add a new package
to our project named data
to encapsulate the data model.
Next, we'll create a contract class
to store our column information.
The inner classes within
our contract class
will be used to define tables.
Each table will implement base columns
because the columns represented
by base columns are useful.
The ID column, in particular,
must be part of our table in order
for our content provider integration
to work later on in this lesson.